philippe douste blazy professeur de
médecine ancien ministre de la santé
bonsoir je vous l'avais dit merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
vient de le voir ces tests sérologiques
du laboratoire pasteur terrain vectis
qui renseigne sur l'efficacité des
anticorps produits par une personne est
ce que c'est une porte sérieuse qui
s'ouvre toute la question aujourd'hui en
effet de savoir si les personnes qui ont
été en contact avec le virus sont
immunisés ou pas l'ensemble de la
communauté scientifique pense en effet
que elles le seront la question c'est
quand combien de temps dans à partir de
quand on a ce qu'on appelle les
anticorps neutralisants arrive
ce sont des études qu'ils ont fait comme
vous le savez aujourd'hui il n'y a que 6
à 7% de la population qui est cassé un
décor et donc c'est tout le sujet du
déconfinement sait le faire
progressivement de façon à ce que nous
puissions civic et une un effet rebond
justement philippe douste-blazy ces
anticorps ont dit tout et son contraire
l'om s aimer encore des réserves
aujourd'hui sur la délivrance de ce type
de passeport immunitaire une idée émise
dit l'om est dans certains pays pour
accompagner le déconfinement comment
s'en sortir dans cette confusion dans
les déclarations des uns et des autres
non je crois que en réalité le vrai
sujet aujourd'hui il est très simple
nous avons 6 à 7% de la population qui
ont été au contact avec des virus
le virus n'a encore circulé et donc je
pense qu'il y aura à peu près entre 2000
et 3000 nouveaux cas par jour on est
très loin bien sûr les soixante mille
cas par jour qu'il y avait il ya un mois
et donc la question est de trouver de
tester de mettre en place un système sur
le terrain pour trouver les personnes
qui sont positives à pâtir de la savoir
qui
elles sont contactés elles ont vu ils
ont rencontré depuis quinze jours trois
semaines et pour les personnes positives
les isoler et c'est comme ça que l'on
arrivera à casser cette épidémie donc
c'est c'est ça la réalité du sujet
aujourd'hui c'est celle là c'est
certainement pas les tests sérologiques
alors philippe douste-blazy là vous nous
parlez si je ne me trompe pas de
l'exemple allemand
est ce qu'aujourd'hui tout simplement en
france et notamment le 11 mai ce qu'on
aura les moyens de faire comme les
allemands de tester suffisamment
d'isoler comme vous dites les patients
infectés est ce que ça sera le cas vous
y croyez vous êtes optimiste
alors ça c'est le grand sujet en effet
comme vous le savez l'allemagne la corée
du sud taïwan
enfin tous les pays qui ont une
mortalité qui à peu près quatre fois
mois que la nôtre même cinq fois moins
que la nôtre on fait des tests très
important au début donc ça je ne parle
pas de ça parce que ça on verra plus
tard nous sommes dans une période d'
union nationale et dont on ne va pas
polémiquer
la question c'est maintenant est ce que
nous sommes capables à des faits c'est
votre question de le faire la réponse
est oui nous sommes capables de le faire
à une condition c'est de mettre en place
vingt mille personnes qui sur le terrain
vont aller chercher dans les endroits où
le virus circule le plus et on sait très
bien que dans le haut rhin le bas rhin
on teste l'alsace d'un côté l'île de
france de l'autre en particulier la
seine saint denis ou à paris nous 18ème
19ème arrondissement de paris le
véhicule circule et là il faut aller
avec des médecins généralistes médecins
libéraux doivent redevenir ceux qui sont
les fers de lance en première ligne de
cette maladie mais aussi les
travailleurs sociaux des associations
allée voir les personnes les tester et
regardez c'est sans positive nous avons
suffisamment de tests pour le faire je
n'ai pas encore entendu le ministre de
la santé mettre en place wind cela comme
les allemands le front avec 20000
personnes d'origine militaire d'ailleurs
où les 15000 personnes que le
ministre de la santé britannique vient
de décider hier les tests les masques
également qui semble être les clés de la
réussite d'un déconfinement réussi il ya
une confusion les français n'y
comprennent pas grand chose entre ce
grand public sont homologuées ce à 5
euros ce gratuit comment le citoyen s'y
retrouve
je prends d'abord qu'il faut dire que le
masque est un élément important pour
baisser le risque de prendre la maladie
nous avons des pays comme hong kong
singapour août autres à nazis quand
cette culture du basque et on a vu que
100 des conflits de mon sens confinement
pendant et bien la maladie était
totalement endigué donc de masse qu'il
faut pas de prix nobel de médecine pour
le comprendre
le masque ça sert pourquoi parce que
c'est à partir de la bouche et des mains
mais à partir de la bouche que nous
pouvons aéroportée ou envoyer des
gouttelettes à la personne qui est en
face de nous donc l'idéal c'est le
masque chirurgical 90% des cas cités
malheureusement il n'y en a pas pour
tout le monde donc il y aura à partir de
maintenant chez les pharmaciens et je
voudrais saluer le rôle des pharmaciens
et je trouve dommage que les pharmaciens
n'est pas jouer un rôle plus important
jusqu'à maintenant mais aussi chez les
buralistes ou ailleurs des grandes
surfaces des masques alternatif faits de
coton et le cocteau empêche cette cette
transmission en fond de vous verlhac
ashton qui est en face
il faut savoir que dans les transports
en commun moi personnellement je suis
pour que le match soit obligatoire mais
à condition que tout le monde le porte
est donc là vous arrivez à une
efficacité prêter que -90% d'autant plus
que la semaine dernière on a appris que
le début ce nouvel aéroport t il n'y a
pas que les gouttelettes alors edouard
philippe doit présenter son plan de
déconfinement demain vous
êtes médecin vous avez été évidemment
ministre vous savez donc la difficulté
de l'arbitrage entre la décision
politique est celle du domaine médical
qu'attendez-vous de main du premier
ministre du gouvernement en fait la
difficulté pour les autorités nationales
quelles qu'elles soient dans le monde
c'est d'une part d'éviter le rebond
épidémique et d'autre part éviter
l'effondrement économique
donc ce que je crois c'est que le mot
confiance doit être la clé on parle des
écoles on parle des transports en commun
on parle de de beaucoup de choses au
fond pour que le la vie recommence comme
avant
il ya une seule condition majeure c'est
koné confiance
donc il ya eu suffisamment d'erreurs qui
a été fait jusqu'à maintenant pour qu'on
présente maintenant une stratégie
globale et surtout d'état lié concrètes
comme celle dont je viens de parler par
exemple pour aller chercher les cas
positifs et leurs contacts il mangea
dans une confiance il n'y a pas la
confiance sanitaires il n'y aura pas de
reprise économique sérieuse
donc oui j'attends demain qu'il y ait un
certain degré de détail de choses
concrètes de la part du premier ministre
est l'un des points d'achoppement on
parlait de cette difficulté d'arbitrage
entre le politique et le médical cette
illustration avec l'école le retour à
l'école qui fait beaucoup parler le
conseil scientifique aurait clairement
recommandé le retour à l'école en
septembre emmanuel macron arbitré
autrement sans doute aussi pour des
raisons économiques d'une égalité
évidemment mais aussi économiques
on est dans la décision politique qui
peut être regrettable pour le médecin
qu'en pensez vous alors moi à titre
personnel c'est vrai que j'aurais été en
charge du pays
j'aurais fait une rentrée scolaire en
septembre mais nous sommes dans une
période d' union nationale donc je vais
parler de rentrée scolaire
je crois qu'elle peut être fait autant
plus que
c'est que les enfants représentent moins
de 20% des hospitalisations en france
donc non pas de risque et les enfants au
fond et ne peut pas et transmettent peu
le virus
al'inverse de la crypte où ils
transmettent beaucoup le cadre de
laquelle elle transperce
ils transmettent très peu le virus du
corona les russes alors par contre il
faut qu'il y ait des tests qu'ils soient
faits pour les enseignants pour les
employés municipaux départementaux
régionaux en fonction des écoles
primaires des écoles des collèges et des
lycées mais que aussi les papas et les
mamans qui attendent les enfants
puissent être testés si jamais il y
avait un enfant camélat fier qu'on
puisse prendre la température des
enfants et s'il ya un enfant qui a
particulièrement la fièvre ou à l'air
malade nous tous il faut évidemment
immédiatement testé toute la classe
voire l'école enfin il faut qu'ils
distanciation social dans et compris
lorsqu'ils des jeunes et y compris dans
les classes avec des gels
hydroalcooliques et bien évidemment
regardé de très très près testez de très
près l'ensemble des personnes qui sont
autour des enfants
une dernière question philippe
douste-blazy une cargaison chloroquine à
destination de l'armée a été filmé et
diffusé sur les réseaux sociaux à la
suscité de nombreuses réactions
le ministère a expliqué que aulas il se
prépare et on a d'efficacité avérée du
traitement conclut commis 19 vous
connaissez bien le sujet puisque vous
siégez ali us méditerranée il ya eu
beaucoup de suspicions sur ce médicament
mais l'état on achète au cas où c'est
surprenant selon vous bon c'est une
discussion qui a eu lieu ce que l'on
sait aujourd'hui c'est que le taux de
mortalité dans les bouches du rhône où
il y a cette stratégie du professeur
round à la fois de tester très largement
pour avoir les cas précoce et les
traités avec des antiviraux abouti à une
mortalité qui est beaucoup plus basse
qu'en france de la même manière au maroc
l'algérie au sénégal où on traite avec
ce protocole il y à une mortalité qui
est pratiquement identique est très
basse et donc il y à là progressivement
c'est vrai une absence de preuves par
des essais cliniques que l'on a en
général en temps de paix mais là nous
sommes dans l'urgence est donc voilà on
a les résultats de mortalité
malheureusement les tests qui ont été
faits des essais cliniques qui ont été
faits en france les deux roues le site
lors qu'ils ne pourront pas être parlant
puisqu'on a donné en français toxiques
lookheed aux personnes qui ressemble qui
ont des cas sévères
c'est à dire les cas où l'hydroxyde
euros qui n'est pas efficace qu'on ne
pourra pas encore une fois dé définir si
le seco qui devrait efficace en tout cas
des taux de mortalité sont très parlants
merci beaucoup philippe douste-blazy lee
professeur de médecine ancien ministre
de la santé merci à vous